When the phone calls started, Meron Estefanos was leading a quiet, busy life. She was a single mom with two young boys, going to school, holding down a couple jobs, including working as a freelance radio reporter. She'd been born in Eritrea in East Africa, moved to Sweden as a teenager. She was living in a suburb of Stockholm.
当电话开始响起时，Meron Estefanos 正过着平静而忙碌的生活。她是一位有两个年幼儿子的单身母亲，不仅要上学，还要打几份工，包括担任自由广播记者。她出生在东非的厄立特里亚，青少年时期移居瑞典。她当时住在斯德哥尔摩的郊区。
She was also a human rights activist, focusing on Eritrea. That's what her radio stories were about, too. And so she was used to people phoning her with tips and leads now and then. But at the end of February 2011 came this phone call--
她还是一位关注厄立特里亚的人权活动家。她的广播报道也是关于这一主题的。因此，她习惯了人们偶尔打来电话提供线索。但在2011年2月底，接到了这样一个电话——
This guy from UK called me and told me that his brother was kidnapped and that he was being asked $20,000 for the release of his brother.
这个来自英国的人给我打电话，告诉我他的兄弟被绑架了，有人向他索要2万美元作为赎金。
The man said his brother was with other people who had been kidnapped, all of them Eritrean, and that they were in the desert, far from Eritrea. They were on the Sinai Peninsula in Egypt, close to the border with Israel. He said they were being tortured and held for ransom-- $20,000 each, which seemed absurdly high to Meron. Eritrea's a country where the average person makes less than $1,000 a year.
那个人说他的兄弟和其他被绑架的人在一起，他们都是厄立特里亚人，而且他们被关在远离厄立特里亚的沙漠里。他们在埃及的西奈半岛，靠近以色列边境。他说他们正在遭受折磨并被扣为人质——每人2万美元，这对Meron来说显得高得离谱。厄立特里亚是一个人均年收入不到1000美元的国家。
I had a hard time believing that, actually, what he was telling me was true. And he understood that people were hard time believing. So he said, well, if you don't believe me, here. So he gave me two phone numbers. He said you can talk to the hostages yourself.
实际上，我很难相信他告诉我的话是真的。他明白人们很难相信。所以他说，好吧，如果你不相信我，给你。于是他给了我两个电话号码。他说你可以亲自和人质谈谈。
Meron wanted it to be a lie. And she couldn't bring herself to try the numbers. But then that night, she couldn't sleep thinking about it. So--
Meron希望那是个谎言。她无法强迫自己拨打这些号码。但那天晚上，她一想到这件事就睡不着觉。于是——
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
Hello?
喂？
Hello.
喂。
Hello, salaam. Meron Estefanos. [SPEAKING TIGRINYA]
喂，salaam（和平）。我是Meron Estefanos。[用提格雷语说话]
Meron called the numbers. And remember, she was a radio reporter. She did reporting for two radio stations that broadcast by shortwave and satellite into Eritrea and over the internet to Eritrean emigres around the world. So she recorded these phone calls, hoping she could do a story. This is one of the first calls she made. And yes, someone did pick up, and yes, he said he was being held hostage. He told her his name was Biniam, he was 22 years old, that he'd fled Eritrea in 2010, had been living in a refugee camp in Sudan, working at a farm, when he was kidnapped and taken to Sinai.
Meron拨打了这些号码。记住，她是一名广播记者。她为两个电台做报道，这些电台通过短波和卫星向厄立特里亚广播，并通过互联网向世界各地的厄立特里亚移民播放。所以她录下了这些电话，希望能做出一篇报道。这是她拨出的第一批电话之一。没错，有人接听了，他也确实说自己被扣为人质。他告诉她，他的名字叫Biniam，今年22岁，他于2010年逃离厄立特里亚，一直住在苏丹的一个难民营里，在一家农场工作，当时他被绑架并带到了西奈半岛。
He said he was there with other people in a group of 28. There had been 29, he said, but one had died. They were being held by some Bedouins, Biniam said. Meron came to learn that the hostages were allowed access to cell phones so they could beg their families to send money. We have interpreters translating what Biniam and Meron said to each other.
他说他和另外28个人在一起。他说原本有29个人，但有一个已经死了。Biniam说他们被一些贝都因人扣押。Meron后来了解到，人质被允许使用手机，这样他们就可以乞求家人汇钱。我们有口译员在翻译Biniam和Meron之间的对话。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
The place we are held at is an underground facility. They have us chained. And they have taken three people to the outside. We hear cries from the outside. We don't know whether they are being tortured or whether they are dead.
我们被关在一个地下设施里。他们把我们锁在一起。他们带走了三个人到外面。我们听到外面传来哭喊声。我们不知道他们是在遭受折磨还是已经死了。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Tell me more. What are they saying to you?
再多告诉我一点。他们对你说了什么？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
The people who are holding us are saying that unless we make good on our investment, there will not be a solution. They tell us they will drink our blood.
扣押我们的人说，除非我们支付投资回报，否则不会有解决办法。他们告诉我们，他们会喝我们的血。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Meron had heard stories of Eritreans being kidnapped and held hostage in the Sinai before this call. People had been fleeing Eritrea for years. Its government is one of the most repressive in the world. And sometimes, people got kidnapped, either on their way out on the road or from refugee camps right across the border.
在这次通话之前，Meron就听说过厄立特里亚人被绑架并在西奈半岛沦为人质的故事。人们多年来一直逃离厄立特里亚。其政府是世界上最压迫的政府之一。有时，人们在逃离途中的路上或刚跨过边境的难民营中被绑架。
But it was still this shadowy thing that human rights groups were just starting to report on at that point in 2011. It wasn't clear how many people it was happening to. And the ransom surprised her, like I said-- the size of it, $20,000. Meron had never heard of a ransom that high. It didn't seem like it could be real. And come on, we'll drink your blood? Really? It could even be some kind of hoax, a scam where they trump up how desperate they were, to get money sent.
但直到2011年那一刻，这仍然是一个人权组织才刚刚开始报道的隐秘事件。目前还不清楚有多少人遭遇了这种情况。正如我所说，赎金让她感到惊讶——数额之大，2万美元。Meron从未听说过那么高的赎金。这看起来不像是真的。而且，拜托，我们要喝你的血？真的吗？这甚至可能是一种骗局，一种夸大他们绝望程度来骗取钱财的诈骗。
I kept telling myself, OK. Maybe they are lying. It's just too hard to believe that this many people can get kidnapped and tortured and a lot of money. It's just hard. But at the same time, I kept saying to myself, what if it's true and I did not believe them? Then I'll regret this the rest of my life.
我一直在告诉自己，好吧。也许他们在撒谎。仅仅是因为太难相信这么多人会被绑架、折磨并索要巨额钱财。这太难了。但与此同时，我一直在对自己说，如果这是真的而我却不相信他们呢？那么我余生都会为此感到后悔。
So Meron calls back. And thanks to caller ID, they call her back. And then, reluctantly, she gets pulled in deeper and deeper into this situation where it is not clear exactly what is true and what isn't, and there are people who are saying their lives are in imminent danger, and it's happening thousands of miles away. But it is also happening right there in her own home, over the telephone. Imagine for a second if hostages started phoning you at your house, while you're at the dinner table, while you're sleeping.
于是Meron回拨了电话。多亏了来电显示，他们也给她回了电话。随后，她很不情愿地被越陷越深，卷入了这个无法明确真相的处境中，有人声称他们的生命处于迫在眉睫的危险之中，而这一切发生在几千英里之外。但这同时也通过电话发生在她的家中。想象一下，如果人质开始给你家打电话，就在你吃饭的时候，在你睡觉的时候。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass as you'll hear, Meron ends up making lots of recordings over the phone and gets more and more involved with these people who are claiming to be hostages. And reporter Yowei Shaw; one of our producers, Brian Reed; and an Eritrean journalist, Bealfan Haile went through those recordings.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。正如你将听到的，Meron最终通过电话录下了大量内容，并与这些声称是人质的人联系越来越紧密。记者Yowei Shaw；我们的制片人之一Brian Reed；以及厄立特里亚记者Bealfan Haile整理了这些录音。
According to the United Nations High Commissioner for Refugees, there are now more migrants and displaced people in the world than ever-- over 65 million. This is a story about the severe danger some of them face. A warning to listeners-- this is a story of hostages and people having their lives threatened. There is some content that is violent and probably not right for children to listen to. Here's reporter Yowei Shaw.
根据联合国难民署的数据，世界上现在的移民和流离失所者比以往任何时候都多——超过6500万。这是一个关于他们中一些人面临严重危险的故事。给听众一个警告——这是一个关于人质和生命受到威胁的故事。其中包含一些暴力内容，可能不适合儿童收听。以下是记者Yowei Shaw的报道。
Meron had a lot of questions for these people on the phone. She started with Biniam, the guy you just heard.
Meron对电话里的这些人有很多疑问。她从Biniam开始，就是你们刚才听到的那个人。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
So tell me, explain to me, from morning till night, what does your day look like?
那么告诉我，给我解释一下，从早到晚，你的一天是怎么过的？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I cannot even begin to describe the situation in here. They come here every hour, and they torture us. They get us up in the morning. We do not get breakfast, but they get breakfast. And they torture us.
我甚至无法形容这里的情况。他们每隔一小时就进来一次，折磨我们。他们早上把我们叫醒。我们没有早餐，但他们有早餐。然后他们折磨我们。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
And towards the evening, after they torture us for so many hours, they give us one bread and they give us very small amounts of water.
到了晚上，在折磨了我们那么多小时之后，他们会给我们一块面包和极少量的水。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
We've been tortured so much that we have wounds all over our backs, and we have lost our appetites as a result of that. We spend our days yearning for death.
我们受到的折磨太严重了，以至于我们背上到处都是伤口，由于折磨，我们已经失去了胃口。我们整天都在渴望死亡。
Meron listened, took notes, finished with Biniam. And then he passed her on to the next hostage, and then the next-- a 21-year-old named Dejen who told her that he and about five of the others were almost completely naked. For 28 days, he'd been wearing just his underwear.
Meron听着，做着笔记，和Biniam结束了谈话。然后他把电话转给了下一个人质，接着是下一个——一个名叫Dejen的21岁年轻人，他告诉她，他和大约五个同伴几乎赤身裸体。28天来，他只穿着内裤。
Do they beat you up?
他们殴打你吗？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
We could have actually gotten used to the beating, but they're introducing us to new methods of torture that were unknown to us. They come here every hour after having tea and food, and they start electrocuting us on our heads as one person steps on our legs.
我们其实已经习惯了挨打，但他们正在向我们引入我们从未见过的新的折磨方法。他们吃过茶和食物后，每小时都来这里，然后踩着我们的腿，电击我们的头部。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
To them, our lives are much less valuable than a goat or any animal.
对他们来说，我们的生命还不如一只山羊或任何动物值钱。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
OK, Dejen. I'll contact you and keep checking on you again. I will broadcast all this information and the numbers that you've given me. Just stay strong, that's all I can say, and continue to encourage each other. I will call you again.
好吧，Dejen。我会联系你并继续关注你的情况。我会广播所有这些信息以及你给我的号码。保持坚强，这是我唯一能说的，并继续互相鼓励。我会再给你打电话的。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Is there anyone else who wants to talk to me?
还有其他人想跟我说话吗？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Yeah, there's one guy here.
是，这里有一个人。
OK, so please pass the phone.
好的，请把电话给他。
Hello?
喂？
Hello.
喂。
Hello. [SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
喂。[用提格雷语说话]。
Meron talked to the fourth hostage, the fifth, the six. They were shackled together in groups of five to 10 people. The traffickers would electrocute them, melt plastic bags, and drip the hot liquid on their backs. They said, we own you. You need to bring $20,000. If not, another option we have is we can simply open you up and harvest your kidneys and hearts.
Meron与第四、第五、第六个人质进行了交谈。他们被5到10人一组地锁在一起。人贩子会电击他们，融化塑料袋，将热液体滴在他们的背上。他们说，我们拥有你们。你们需要交出2万美元。如果不交，我们还有另一个选择，我们可以直接剖开你们，取出你们的肾脏和心脏。
By the time Meron was talking to the eighth hostage, Yohannes, you can hear in the recording that she's at a loss for what to say. She just keeps repeating, stay strong.
当Meron与第八个人质Yohannes谈话时，你可以从录音中听出她不知道该说什么了。她只是不断重复，保持坚强。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Stay strong, and if there's anything new, I will call you and let you know. But right now, all I can say is stay strong and continue to encourage each other.
保持坚强，如果有任何新情况，我会打电话通知你。但现在，我唯一能说的就是保持坚强，继续互相鼓励。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I'm sorry. Are we done for now?
对不起。我们现在谈完了吗？
Meron had been talking to the hostages for nearly an hour, and she couldn't absorb any more. But another hostage got on, Semereab.
Meron与人质谈话已经快一个小时了，她无法再承受更多。但另一个人质Semereab接过了电话。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
You're our only hope. We spend our days wondering whether death will come today or tomorrow.
你是我们唯一的希望。我们整天都在猜测死亡是今天来还是明天来。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
The next hour or the next minute.
下一小时还是下一分钟。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
OK, stay strong.
好吧，保持坚强。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I don't even know what else I can do or what else I can say. There is nothing else I can say. There's not much I can do as an individual.
我甚至不知道我还能做什么或说什么。我没有别的可说了。作为个人，我能做的不多。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
OK, are we done for now? Or is there anyone else?
好吧，我们现在谈完了吗？或者还有其他人吗？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Yeah, there are others.
是的，还有其他人。
But Meron had heard all she could take. She cut the call short.
但Meron已经听到了她所能承受的一切。她切断了通话。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Can we stop here for now? And maybe next time when I call, I can talk to the others?
我们现在可以先到这里吗？也许下次我打电话时，我可以和别人谈谈？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Say bye to them for me, and tell them to stay strong.
替我跟他们说再见，告诉他们要保持坚强。
Please don't disappear on us, and call us every now and then.
请不要从我们这里消失，偶尔给我们打个电话。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Meron hung up and sat at her desk, staring at a computer screen.
Meron挂断了电话，坐在书桌前，盯着电脑屏幕。
What can you feel? It's just shock. It was hard to accept what I was hearing, the stories they were telling me, the things they were going through. I was just-- from a normal life, it's like going to another world that you never thought existed.
你会有什么感觉？只有震惊。很难接受我听到的东西，他们告诉我的故事，他们正在经历的事情。我只是——从正常的生活，就像进入了另一个你从未想过存在的世界。
She still wasn't entirely certain whether this call was legit, or if it was, how much of what she was being told was real. But she knew it might be real. She knew it was true that Eritreans were being held in Sinai. And if these 28 people were there, maybe she could help them.
她仍然不能完全确定这个电话是否合法，或者如果是真的，她所被告知的事情有多少是真实的。但她知道这可能是真的。她知道厄立特里亚人被关在西奈半岛确实是事实。如果这28个人在那里，也许她能帮助他们。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Meron began broadcasting her interviews on Tigrinya-language radio stations. These were not carefully-crafted feature stories. She felt she didn't have time for that. They were basically raw, unedited recordings of her phone calls, with hostages describing the torture and begging for help on the air.
Meron开始在提格雷语广播电台播放她的采访内容。这些不是精心制作的专题报道。她觉得没时间那样做。它们基本上是她电话录音的原始、未剪辑版，人质在空中描述折磨并恳求帮助。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Meron also reached out to other reporters to try and get them to cover the story.
Meron还联系了其他记者，试图让他们报道这个故事。
Oh, it's a very touching story, but it wouldn't sell. That's the kind of reply I would get when I called to some journalists that I knew. Sorry, we can't help you. Oh, it's not connected to Sweden. Sorry. So this is the kind of reply that I was getting.
哦，这是一个非常感人的故事，但卖不出去。这是我打电话给相识的记者时得到的回应。对不起，我们帮不了你。哦，这跟瑞典没关系。对不起。这就是我得到的回复。
Meron did manage to get a BBC reporter interested in the hostages' story, but he asked for proof. How could he verify that people were being held and tortured in Sinai? She put him in touch with a group of doctors, Physicians for Human Rights Israel, who'd been helping and interviewing Eritreans coming out of Sinai. They'd photographed people's injuries from beatings, shackles, and burns.
Meron确实设法让一位BBC记者对人质的故事产生了兴趣，但他要求提供证据。他怎么能证实人们在西奈半岛被拘留和折磨呢？她让他与一群医生取得了联系，那是“以色列医生促进人权组织”，他们一直在帮助和采访从西奈半岛出来的厄立特里亚人。他们拍下了人们遭受殴打、戴手铐和烧伤的伤口。
In the end, though, BBC story didn't seem to get any attention. Meron went on a phone and email blitz, trying to publicize the issue but also hoping that something could be done for these 28 people. She contacted governments, NGOs, the United Nations Refugee Agency.
然而最终，BBC的故事似乎没有得到任何关注。Meron开始了电话和电子邮件狂轰滥炸，试图宣传这个问题，但也希望这28个人能得到营救。她联系了各国政府、非政府组织和联合国难民署。
There was a lot of disappointment at the time-- disappointment of all institutions and disappointed at journalists because I thought that within weeks, I would be able to solve it.
当时非常令人失望——对所有机构感到失望，也对记者感到失望，因为我以为几周内我就能解决它。
Some organizations were taking small steps, like pressuring Egypt to take action. Early 2011 was incredibly bad timing for anyone trying to fix a problem in Sinai. The Arab Spring was going strong. Egypt was going through a revolution. Meron first got in touch with the hostages the same month that Egypt's president, Hosni Mubarak, was forced to step down.
一些组织正在采取小步骤，比如向埃及施压，要求其采取行动。2011年初对任何试图解决西奈半岛问题的人来说时机都非常糟糕。阿拉伯之春正在如火如荼地进行。埃及正在经历一场革命。Meron第一次与人质取得联系的那个月，正是埃及总统穆巴拉克被迫下台的时候。
There was no government. That was a problem. They didn't have government, so that was also one of the biggest problems that we had because we didn't know who to talk to because there was no government.
没有政府。那是一个问题。他们没有政府，所以这也是我们面临的最大问题之一，因为我们不知道该找谁谈，因为没有政府。
Hello.
喂。
Hello, hello. Biniam?
喂，喂。Biniam？
The hostages continued to call Meron, and the one she talked to the most was Biniam, the first guy in that phone call she recorded. He became kind of a spokesman for the group, and they developed a good rapport.
人质们继续给Meron打电话，她谈话最多的是Biniam，那个她在电话录音里遇到的第一个人。他成了该团体的发言人，他们建立了良好的融洽关系。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Very soon, Meron was talking to Biniam nearly every day, often multiple times a day. She wanted to move on from the story, but the calls wouldn't stop.
很快，Meron几乎每天都在和Biniam通话，通常一天多次。她想离开这个故事，但电话不停。
They saved my number, so it was really hard to even avoid it, even if I wanted to. I really wanted to avoid it. I could not just ignore those phone calls.
他们保存了我的号码，所以即使我想避免也很难。我真的想避免。我不能就那样忽略那些电话。
The way it worked is the hostages would call and hang up before she answered so she could see their number and call back, since they didn't have enough phone credit. And in these conversations, Meron was always trying to figure out what was real in what the hostages were telling her. She knew that some amount of torture and killing needed to be happening to convince hostages' families to pay the insanely high ransoms.
运作方式是人质会在她接听之前打电话并挂断，这样她就能看到他们的号码并回拨，因为他们的电话费不够。在这些谈话中，Meron总是试图弄清楚人质告诉她的哪些是真实的。她知道必须发生一定程度的折磨和杀戮，才能让受害者的家属支付高昂得离谱的赎金。
But the traffickers couldn't kill too many people. It would cut into profits. So she figured they forced the hostages to exaggerate or lie sometimes. Still, she felt she could tell real panic when she heard it.
但人贩子不能杀太多人。那会削减利润。所以她猜他们有时会强迫人质夸大其词或撒谎。尽管如此，她觉得当她听到真正的恐慌时，她是能分辨出来的。
Hello, hello? Meron, Meron.
喂，喂？Meron，Meron。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Meron, Meron, two people have died just now.
Meron，Meron，刚刚有两个人死了。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Oh, my God. Who has died now? Who did they-- what did they do? Tell me what happened.
天哪。是谁死了？他们——他们做了什么？告诉我发生了什么。
On March 6, eight days after she first started recording the hostages, Meron called them to check in, and a guy named Medhane picked up. A warning-- this call has explicit violence.
3月6日，在第一次录下人质谈话八天后，Meron打电话给他们了解情况，一个叫Medhane的人接了电话。警告——这个电话有露骨的暴力描写。
Even me, my legs are crushed right now. I'm gathering all my strength to speak to you, Meron, my sister.
连我自己，我的腿现在都碎了。我正在鼓起所有力气和你说话，Meron，我的姐妹。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
We have two hours left. Please help us.
我们只剩两个小时了。请救救我们。
Just tell me, what is it that has happened? Tell me. What happened?
告诉我，到底发生了什么？告诉我。发生了什么？
They came in to beat us as usual. And they told everyone to raise their legs. When those two couldn't do it anymore and lowered their legs, they killed them.
他们进来像往常一样打我们。他们让每个人都抬起腿。当那两个人再也做不到放下腿时，他们杀了他们。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Please, please do something. I am losing so much blood that I don't think I will make it through the night.
请，请做点什么。我失血过多，我想我挺不过今晚了。
The hostage pleaded with Meron to send money as soon as possible, and then Meron heard a noise in the background.
人质恳求Meron尽快汇钱，然后Meron听到了背景中的噪音。
[CRACKING SOUND]
[破碎声]
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
[CRACKING SOUND]
[破碎声]
He said the traffickers were beating them right then and there.
他说人贩子正在此时此刻殴打他们。
The others are being tortured as we speak. Please, it's an emergency.
我们说话的时候其他人正在被折磨。求求你，这是紧急情况。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Meron is saying, oh, you poor guys, you poor guys. And there was one hostage in particular, Meron told them, she had to speak to-- the only woman in the group, an 18-year-old named Semhar.
Meron说，噢，你们这些可怜的人，你们这些可怜的人。Meron告诉他们，有一个特别的人质她必须交谈——这是该组中唯一的女性，一个名叫Semhar的18岁女孩。
Hello? Hello?
喂？喂？
Hello, Semhar.
喂，Semhar。
Hello, Semhar? Good morning, Semharina. I'm very sad. They've told me everything that's going on.
喂，Semhar？早上好，Semharina。我很伤心。他们已经把发生的一切都告诉我了。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Please, Meron, my sister, please. Please help us.
求求你，Meron，我的姐妹，求求你。请救救我们。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Semhar had been kidnapped while living in a refugee camp in Sudan, like Biniam and some of the other hostages with her. She had left Eritrea in hopes of finding a job to support her mom, who was very poor and trying to raise four young children she'd taken in. Meron felt especially close to Semhar.
Semhar是在苏丹的一个难民营里被绑架的，像Biniam和她在一起的其他一些人质一样。她离开厄立特里亚是为了找一份工作来支持她非常贫穷、努力抚养四个收养的幼小孩子的母亲。Meron觉得和Semhar特别亲近。
And during this call, Semhar kept telling Meron how terrified she was, how she was on the verge of death, how she just couldn't bear it anymore. Meron started crying.
在这次通话中，Semhar一直告诉Meron她是多么害怕，她是多么濒临死亡，她是多么无法再忍受了。Meron开始哭了。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Her story really touched me, and now I feel like she's my younger sister. I mean, I've heard so many people crying in the Sinai. But she's a very special girl that just, I mean, the way she would beg was really--
她的故事真的打动了我，现在我觉得她就像我的小妹妹。我是说，我听过太多人在西奈半岛哭泣。但她是一个非常特别的女孩，只是，那种恳求的方式真的——
How would she beg? How was it different?
她是怎么恳求的？有什么不同？
I mean, it's just different. Like she would say, my sister, Meron, please, please. I don't know. It's hard. You have to understand Tigrinya to get it. So it was just different.
我是说，就是不同。比如她会说，我的姐妹，Meron，求求你，求求你。我不知道。这很难。你得懂提格雷语才能明白。所以就是不同。
In fact, as we were interpreting the phone call you just heard, when we got to Semhar, our interpreter, who'd been listening to these recordings for hours, began crying herself and had to stop. She said she'd never heard anyone beg like that.
事实上，当我们翻译你刚才听到的那个电话时，当我们谈到Semhar时，我们的口译员听了这些录音几个小时了，她自己也开始哭了，不得不停下来。她说她从未听过有人那样恳求过。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
And the male hostages who were in captivity with Semhar felt the same way. They told Meron that Semhar had it especially bad, even worse than them. One of the guards was taking her at night, and she came back crying. They didn't know what he was doing with her.
和Semhar一起被关押的男性人质也有同感。他们告诉Meron，Semhar的情况特别糟糕，比他们还严重。其中一个守卫晚上会带走她，她回来时在哭。他们不知道他对她做了什么。
They were saying, we know that you cannot save all of us. We are 28 people. But at least save this girl, and then we'll be happy.
他们说，我们知道你救不了我们所有人。我们有28个人。但至少救救这个女孩，那我们就心满意足了。
Meron recorded all of these phone calls from the living room of her one-bedroom apartment, surrounded by photographs of her kids and lemon-painted walls in the woods of a quiet suburb of Stockholm. Hostages called at all hours-- during meals or in the middle of the night or early in the morning. She'd have to watch her boys while talking to the hostages. You can sometimes hear her kids in the recordings playing nearby.
Meron在斯德哥尔摩宁静郊区的一处树林里，在她一居室公寓的客厅里录下了所有这些电话，四周挂着她孩子的照片，墙壁漆成了柠檬色。人质会在任何时间打来电话——在吃饭时，半夜，或清晨。她一边和人质谈话，一边还得照顾她的孩子。你有时可以在录音里听到她的孩子在附近玩耍。
And it wasn't the kind of work that ended when she hung up the phone.
而且这根本不是那种挂断电话就结束的工作。
I couldn't sleep. All I was doing is just crying. And the first three weeks, I couldn't even take care of my kids because I was just almost going crazy. The screams were just-- I could hear the screams 24 hours in my head. I couldn't breathe. Sometimes when you're tired, you say [EXHALES]. And that feels good, to breathe out. But for three weeks, I couldn't do that. I would be trying-- [EXHALES]-- and still, it doesn't come out.
我睡不着。我所做的就是哭。前三周，我甚至没法照顾我的孩子，因为我快疯了。尖叫声只是——我24小时在脑子里都能听到那些尖叫声。我无法呼吸。有时当你累了，你会说[呼气]。那感觉很好，呼出一口气。但有三周，我做不到那样。我会试图——[呼气]——仍然，出不来。
I remember it was around 11:00 at night. And I had quit smoking for a very long time. And it was, like, five to 11:00. And the store near my house closes at 11:00. And I was rushing to buy cigarettes. And I remember taking the first smoke, and it was like for the first time, I was able to breathe out. I could exhale, and it felt really good.
我记得那大约是晚上11点。我已经戒烟很久了。那是11点差5分。我家附近的商店11点关门。我冲去买烟。我记得抽了第一口，就像我第一次能呼出气一样。我能呼气，感觉真的很好。
Things only seemed to be getting worse. The hostages told her that a fifth person had died, and Meron says that's when she reached a turning point.
情况似乎只会变得更糟。人质告诉她，第五个人已经死了，Meron说那正是她达到转折点的时候。
That's when I decided now, I cannot take this. I cannot just sit by, and the world is not doing anything. At least I have to save one person. And that's when I decided to do fundraising to collect money for the girl, that Semhar will be the one.
那就是我决定的时候，我受不了了。我不能只是袖手旁观，而世界什么都不做。至少我必须救一个人。所以我决定筹款，为人质Semhar收集钱，她会是那个人。
Meron knew that paying ransom was a bad idea. She knew it just encouraged more hostage-taking, and she knew it might not work. The traffickers could take her $20,000 and still not let Semhar go. Also, it was so much money. She'd raised money for causes before, but never that much.
Meron知道支付赎金是个坏主意。她知道这只会鼓励更多的人质绑架，而且她知道这可能不起作用。人贩子拿了她的2万美元却还是不放走Semhar。而且，那是很多钱。她以前为事业筹过钱，但从未筹过那么多。
At the beginning, I didn't believe that someone should pay. And I thought that if the international community knows about it, they would just send soldiers or something and rescue them. That's the way I was thinking. But then you start realizing that you are on your own. Nobody will save these people. And one by one, they start dying. So I could not take the phone calls that when I called the next day, they would tell me, oh, he just died. And he just died.
起初，我不相信有人应该付钱。我想如果国际社会知道这件事，他们会直接派遣士兵或什么的营救他们。我当时就是那样想的。但随后你开始意识到你是孤身一人的。没有人会救这些人。他们一个接一个地死去了。所以我无法忍受当我第二天打电话时，他们会告诉我，噢，他刚刚死了。他又死了。
So when five people died, that's when I decided, who cares if it's wrong or not? But I want to try, at least, to save one person so that I don't have a guilty feeling that I didn't try.
所以当五个人死后，我就决定，谁在乎对不对？但我至少想试着救一个人，这样我就不会有没尽力而产生的负罪感。
So Meron began asking for money. She wrote posts on Facebook and used Paltalk, a social media voice chat where a lot of Eritreans hang out. At night, she went into different chat rooms, making her appeal. She got Eritrean ex-pats in the US, Norway, and the UK to collect money from people in their respective countries.
于是Meron开始要钱。她在Facebook上发贴，并使用了Paltalk，这是一个很多厄立特里亚人聚集的社交媒体语音聊天平台。晚上，她进入不同的聊天室，发出呼吁。她让在美国、挪威和英国的厄立特里亚侨民从各自国家的人那里筹钱。
But donations came slowly-- $20 here, $50 there. People were reluctant to give money for a ransom payment, understandably. She also had to contend with the internal politics of the Eritrean diaspora. Meron's pretty well-known as a strong opponent of the Eritrean government, and there are still large groups of Eritreans in the diaspora that support the government. So they didn't trust Meron. Some claimed she and the hostages were making the whole situation up to make the government look bad.
但捐款来得很慢——20美元这里，50美元那里。人们不太愿意为支付赎金捐款，这是可以理解的。她还得应对厄立特里亚侨民内部的政治。Meron作为一个坚决反对厄立特里亚政府的人相当出名，而侨民中仍有大批支持政府的厄立特里亚人。所以他们不信任Meron。有些人声称她和人质编造了整个局势，目的是为了让政府难堪。
They were saying, it must be a made-up something like for radio, like a drama or something. They thought I made it up. So I said, well, if you don't believe me, here. Here is the number. You can call them yourself. That was really stupid of me.
他们说，这一定是编造的东西，为了广播，就像是一部剧什么的。他们认为是我编造的。所以我说，好吧，如果你不相信我，给你。这是号码。你可以亲自给他们打电话。我当时真蠢。
It was stupid because people did take the hostages' phone number and started calling them, Biniam and the others, but not for the reason Meron had hoped.
这很蠢，因为人们确实拿到了人质的电话号码并开始给Biniam和其他人打电话，但不是出于Meron希望的原因。
They started calling and cursing at them, saying, you think you can play us? You're not going to get anything, a cent out of us, and calling them names, and told the girl that she is a whore trying to make money out of Eritreans.
他们开始打电话诅咒他们，说，你们以为能耍我们吗？你们一分钱也别想从我们这儿拿到，并叫他们名字，告诉那个女孩她是一个试图利用厄立特里亚人赚钱的妓女。
On the phone afterwards, Biniam told Meron it really upset him.
事后在电话里，Biniam告诉Meron这让他非常难过。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
They've been calling us all night. They would say we are jihadists. We are swindlers. And they are accusing us of actually trying to get them to send us money.
他们整晚都在给我们打电话。他们会说我们是圣战分子。我们是骗子。他们指责我们实际上是在试图让他们给我们汇钱。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
For Biniam, the fact that people didn't believe them struck at the one thing that was giving him even a shred of optimism-- the thought that Meron would be able to rally people on the outside to come to their rescue. He was losing faith in Meron.
对Biniam来说，人们不相信他们的事实打击了他仅存的一丝乐观——即Meron能够团结外面的人来营救他们的想法。他开始对Meron失去信心。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
We've trusted you, and we've become extremely hopeless when we hear such talk coming from you and the other people.
我们信任你，当我们听到你和其他人说这种话时，我们感到极其绝望。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Biniam, my brother, I believe you. I don't think you're pretending.
Biniam，我的兄弟，我相信你。我不认为你在假装。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
But you're all by yourself in this.
但你在这件事上是孤身一人。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
What can you accomplish all by yourself?
你自己一个人能成就什么？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
We really do not want to trouble you.
我们真的不想给你添麻烦。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
If no one's willing to bail us out, we are all ready to commit suicide here.
如果没人愿意帮我们交保释金，我们都准备在这里自杀了。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Don't say that. Don't say that. There are people all over fighting for you.
别那么说。别那么说。全世界都有人在为你战斗。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
But what are we supposed to do? If you are the only one in this, we understand that you can not do anything. Meron, my sister, one hand cannot clap by itself. It's meaningless.
但我们该怎么办？如果你是这里唯一一个，我们明白你什么也做不了。Meron，我的姐妹，一只手拍不响。这毫无意义。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I am in such a dire situation. Because of the injuries that I have sustained in my head, my health is deteriorating on a daily basis. I believe that I'm going to die. Well, if you ever give birth to a boy, please name him Biniam after me.
我处于如此可怕的境地。由于我头部受的伤，我的健康状况每天都在恶化。我相信我会死的。好吧，如果你生了个男孩，请以我的名字命名为Biniam。
Some hostages, like Biniam, Meron was talking to you nearly every day, sometimes several times a day. But there were always new ones, too. One day early on, Meron got a call. A hostage began talking to her.
有些像Biniam这样的人质，Meron几乎每天都在和你谈话，有时一天多次。但总是有新的人加入。有一天早些时候，Meron接到一个电话。一个人质开始跟她说话。
Hello.
喂。
Hello, hello?
喂，喂？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
And after a few minutes, she realized, wait, this isn't the same group of hostages I've been talking to. This is a whole different group of 31 people in the same situation-- being tortured and extorted for money in Sinai.
几分钟后，她意识到，等等，这不是我一直在谈论的同一组人质。这是另一组31人，处于同样的情况——在西奈半岛被折磨和敲诈钱财。
Somehow, they found out about me, and they got my number. And then they called, and I started talking to them, interviewing them, broadcasting it on the radio. And then after a week or so, then another group heard of me. So it became-- within a month, it was about six different groups of hostages that I was interviewing, like the group with 28, and then 31.
不知何故，他们发现了我的存在，并得到了我的号码。然后他们打来电话，我开始和他们交谈、采访他们，并在广播中播放出来。然后大概一周左右，另一组人听说了我。所以它变成了——一个月内，我就在采访大约六个不同的人质小组，比如有28人的小组，然后是31人。
Hello.
喂。
Hello, hello?
喂，喂？
And then the third group were 71 people there.
然后第三组有71个人在那里。
Hello.
喂。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
And then the fourth were about 150 people. Then I stopped counting. It became too much. Everybody started calling me.
然后第四组大约150人。然后我就不数了。太多了。每个人都开始给我打电话。
At first, Meron was reluctant to get involved with other groups. But not surprisingly, she got drawn into their situations, as well. And as she spoke to more people, she was able to piece together a clearer picture of the criminal networks that were doing the trafficking. As best she could tell, a small group of Bedouin bosses in Sinai were at the top, but they had connections with gangs of kidnappers in Sudan, who would bring them truckloads of people. And they seemed to have agents in different cities around the world who would collect ransoms for them.
起初，Meron不愿意介入其他小组。但不出所料，她也被卷入了他们的处境中。随着她与更多人交谈，她能够拼凑出对正在进行人口贩卖的犯罪网络的更清晰的图像。据她所知，西奈半岛的一小群贝都因头目处于顶端，但他们与苏丹的绑架团伙有联系，这些团伙会将一车又一车的人带给他们。他们似乎在世界各地的不同城市有代理人，为他们收集赎金。
Meron also learned that there were Eritreans working for the traffickers in the encampments. Some of them were kind of like indentured servants, forced to do construction and cleaning jobs for the traffickers. Others were interpreters, Eritreans who spoke Arabic as well as Tigrinya and served as go-betweens for the Bedouins to help them communicate with the hostages and their families.
Meron还了解到，在这些营地里有为人贩子工作的厄立特里亚人。其中一些人有点像契约仆人，被迫为人贩子做建筑和清洁工作。其他人是口译员，这些厄立特里亚人既会说阿拉伯语又会说提格雷语，充当贝都因人的中间人，帮助他们与人质及其家属沟通。
And in the first hostage group she was talking to, she learned that there was one interpreter in particular named John. She couldn't figure out his place in the hierarchy, whether he was a hostage forced to translate for the traffickers or if he'd actually joined their ring himself. A former hostage and a hostage's brother warned her that he was shady. But then when she asked Biniam and Semhar if John was working with the Bedouins, they told her he wasn't.
在她谈论的第一个人质小组中，她了解到有一个特别的口译员名叫John。她无法弄清他在等级制度中的位置，他到底是被迫为人贩子翻译的人质，还是自己真的加入了他们的团伙。一位前人质和一个人质的兄弟警告她他很阴险。但当她问Biniam和Semhar John是否在和贝都因人合作时，他们告诉她他没有。
So in early April, when John came bearing good news, she didn't know if she could trust him. She had been asking the traffickers for weeks to lower the ransom, and John brought word that they'd agreed. The new price was $5,000 per person. At this point, Meron had already sent $2,000 for Semhar. So this meant she needed to send just $3,000 more, which was a lot more manageable than the original $20,000 price tag, if the discount was actually for real.
所以四月初，当John带来好消息时，她不知道该不该信任他。她几周来一直要求人贩子降低赎金，John带来消息说他们同意了。新价格是每人5000美元。此时，Meron已经为Semhar汇去了2000美元。这意味着如果折扣是真实的，她只需要再汇3000美元，这比最初的2万美元要好应对得多。
She called Biniam to see if it was.
她打电话给Biniam看是否属实。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
So if I pay $3,000 more, he'll let Semhar go, Meron asked Biniam. Yes, Biniam said. If you pay $3,000 more right now, he will let Semhar go. Meron was excited. This was her first break in the whole ordeal. But she soon found out it wasn't that simple.
所以如果我再多汇3000美元，他就会放Semhar走，Meron问Biniam。是的，Biniam说。如果你现在再汇3000美元，他就会放Semhar走。Meron很兴奋。这是她整次折磨中的第一次突破。但她很快发现事情没那么简单。
Yowei Shaw. Coming up, things get precisely five times more complicated in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
Yowei Shaw。接下来，事情会变得复杂五倍，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "This Call May Be Recorded to Save Your Life." We've been hearing a story that we first ran in 2013 about Meron Estefanos, a human rights activist and journalist who was trying to save a group of Eritrean hostages who were being held in Sinai.
这是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“此通话可能已被录音以挽救你的生命”。我们一直在听一个我们最初在2013年播出的故事，是关于Meron Estefanos的，一位试图营救一群被关在西奈半岛的厄立特里亚人质的人权活动家和记者。
In the years since we first aired this story, this problem has actually stopped in the Sinai Peninsula because of increased Egyptian military presence there. But it still continues elsewhere. According to Meron and human rights groups, Eritrean migrants are being held in torture camps and other places, particularly Libya. Meron says Libya is an even worse situation than Sinai was a few years ago.
自我们首次播出这个故事以来的几年里，由于埃及在西奈半岛的军事存在增加，这个问题实际上已经停止了。但它仍然在其他地方持续存在。根据Meron和人权组织的说法，厄立特里亚移民仍然被关押在酷刑营和其他地方，特别是利比亚。Meron说利比亚的情况比几年前的西奈半岛还要糟糕。
At this point in our story, it's been over a month since her first phone call with the hostages, and she's been offered a discount, a break on the price to save one of them, the only woman in the group of 28. Her name was Semhar. Instead of a $20,000 ransom, it would be $5,000 to release her. Release means, in this case, they would drive her to the Israeli border and tell her to run for it.
在我们故事的这一点上，距离她与人质的第一次通话已经过去了一个多月，她得到了一项折扣，一个挽救其中一人的机会，这是28人小组中唯一的女性。她的名字叫Semhar。赎金不再是2万美元，而是5000美元就能释放她。在这种情况下，释放意味着他们会把她开车送到以色列边境并告诉她跑过去。
Just to repeat the warning that I made at the beginning of the program, this is a story with violence and lives being threatened. And there is some content that is probably not right for younger listeners. Yowei Shaw picks up the story from here.
重复一遍我在节目开始时作出的警告，这是一个带有暴力和生命受到威胁的故事。而且其中包含一些内容可能不适合年轻听众。Yowei Shaw从这里接手故事。
Meron called John, the Eritrean who was translating for the Bedouin traffickers. She wanted to finalize the deal to get Semhar out, and John said, for sure. He could do this deal. He knew the Bedouins. And as for the hostages, he said he was looking out for them as best as he could in a very difficult situation.
Meron打电话给John，那个为人贩子贝都因人担任翻译的厄立特里亚人。她想敲定交易把Semhar救出来，John说，肯定的。他能做成这笔交易。他认识贝都因人。至于人质，他说他正尽最大努力在一个非常困难的处境中照顾他们。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Here's the deal.
交易是这样的。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
These are your brothers and sisters, and you're actually advocating for them, right? Me here, when they try to kill them, I try to protect them. And after they are tortured, I try to clean and dress their wounds. I try to wash the blood off their backs.
这些人是你的兄弟姐妹，你实际上是在为他们辩护，对吧？我在这里，当他们试图杀他们时，我试图保护他们。在他们遭受折磨后，我试图清洁并包扎他们的伤口。我试图洗去他们背上的血迹。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I've been doing a lot for them.
我为他们做了很多。
John said the traffickers would do the deal. They would release Semhar for $5,000, but only if at least four other hostages paid $5,000 each at the same time. In other words, the discount only applied if Meron bought in bulk. A friend of Meron's who was on the call with John tried to push back, but John said, basically, don't tell me how to do my job. Just do yours.
John说人贩子会做这笔交易。他们会以5000美元的价格释放Semhar，但前提是至少还有四个人质同时支付5000美元。换句话说，折扣仅在Meron批量购买时才适用。Meron的一个朋友在和John通话时试图拒绝，但John说，基本上，别教我怎么做事。做你自己的事就行。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
You just need to focus on sending the money. If you pay for those five people, I will get them to their destination safely.
你只需要专注于汇钱。如果你为那五个人付了钱，我会让他们安全到达目的地。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Meron was skeptical, but she had no other option. She got in touch with four other families who were willing to pay the discounted ransom. Biniam was not one of these four hostages, by the way. His family was having trouble delivering the money.
Meron持怀疑态度，但她别无选择。她联系了其他四个愿意支付打折赎金的家庭。顺便说一句，Biniam不是这四个人质之一。他的家人在筹钱方面遇到了困难。
The families would pay $5,000 for each of their relatives, and Meron would pay $5,000 for Semhar. Meron put out a frantic call to the people around the world who were helping her collect money for Semhar's ransom. And maybe it was the urgency or maybe it was the fact that $5,000 seemed like a more realistic amount of money to raise than the original $20,000, but people chipped in. Within 48 hours, she had the money she needed.
这些家庭将为他们的亲戚每人支付5000美元，Meron将为Semhar支付5000美元。Meron向世界各地帮助她为人质赎金筹款的人发出了紧急呼吁。也许是紧迫感，也许是5000美元看起来比最初的2万美元更容易筹集，人们捐了款。48小时内，她筹到了所需的钱。
They asked us to send the money using Western Union, which I did. So I called and asked if they got the money. They said yeah and said, well, I'm rushing right now. We're about to drive them to the border of Israel right now. I'll speak to you tomorrow.
他们要求我们用西联汇款寄钱，我也这么做了。所以我打电话问他们有没有收到钱。他们说收到了，并说，好吧，我这会儿很忙。我们正要开车把他们送到以色列边境。我明天再跟你谈。
Meron was so nervous she couldn't sleep. She spent the next 24 hours calling her contacts in Sinai and Israel to see if they had any updates. She tried John again and again. Finally, he picked up.
Meron非常紧张，睡不着觉。她花了接下来24小时给她在西奈和以色列的联系人打电话看是否有最新消息。她一次又一次尝试联系John。最后，他接听了。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Hello, Johnny. [SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
喂，Johnny。[用提格雷语说话]。
John, tell me honestly what have you done, she asked him. I've set five people free, he said.
John，诚实地告诉我你做了什么，她问他。我已经释放了五个人，他说。
I was really happy. So a friend of mine, she came and slept over in my house. This is a woman that was helping me raising money. And we kind of celebrated. I'm thinking, OK. Everything is over now. $5,000 is paid, and she's out.
我真的很开心。所以我的一个朋友过来睡在我家里。这是一个帮我筹钱的女人。我们算是庆祝了一下。我想，好的。现在一切都结束了。5000美元付了，她也出来了。
And then Meron got a call from the brother of one of the other hostages who was supposed to have been freed to Israel.
然后Meron接到了另一名人质兄弟的电话，那个人本该被释放到以色列。
He said, you know, their playing with us because my brother just called me. And he told me that he's in Sinai. And now they are asking for $15,000 more. So it was all a game.
他说，你知道，他们在玩我们，因为我兄弟刚才给我打了电话。他告诉我他在西奈半岛。现在他们还要再要15000美元。所以这完全是一场游戏。
Meron phoned John and asked about Semhar.
Meron给John打电话问Semhar的情况。
I called and said, how could you do this to me? I know that she's there. And then he started calling me names. He didn't care.
我打电话说，你怎么能对我做这种事？我知道她在那儿。然后他开始骂我。他根本不在乎。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I don't give a [BLEEP] about those people.
我才不管那些人的[脏话]。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I don't care about them. They are mother [BLEEP].
我不在乎他们。他们是混蛋。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
You can't say that! You tell us to pay money to have them released, and then when we pay, you won't release them.
你不能这么说！你告诉我们要付钱让他们获释，然后当我们付了钱，你却不放他们。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I don't want to harm anyone. But whether those people live or die is none of my business.
我不想伤害任何人。但这些人是生是死与我无关。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA]. Hello?
[用提格雷语说话]。喂？
John hung up on Meron. A few minutes later, Meron got a missed call. She returned it, and it was the hostages. They insisted that the people who had been paid for had been freed, that they'd made it to Israel. They begged Meron to free them now, too.
John挂断了Meron的电话。几分钟后，Meron接到了一个未接来电。她回拨过去，是人质们。他们坚持说已经付过钱的人已经被释放了，他们已经到达了以色列。他们乞求Meron现在也释放他们。
But she didn't believe them. Her plan had completely failed. It had been five weeks since her first phone call with the hostages, and now she thought John was trying to get more money out of her by forcing the hostages to say these things. Biniam got on the phone.
但她不相信他们。她的计划彻底失败了。距离她与人质的第一次通话已经过去五周了，现在她认为John正试图通过强迫人质说这些话来从她那里榨取更多钱。Biniam接了电话。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
How you been?
你怎么样？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I'm not doing well, Biniam. This is not good.
我不太好，Biniam。这不太好。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
This has become a joke. I'm not going to be able to do anything for you going forward, Biniam.
这已经变成了一个笑话。未来我将无法为你做任何事，Biniam。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I'm going to tell the families not to pay. People pay, and no one is being released.
我会告诉家人不要付钱。人们付了钱，却没有人被释放。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
But they have left.
但他们已经离开了。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
OK, well, once they call me and tell me they've left, that's when I'll call you. But until then, I will not call you.
好的，好吧，一旦他们给我打电话告诉我他们已经离开，那时我才会给你打电话。但在此之前，我不会再给你打电话。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Meron hung up on him. But she couldn't help yourself. It wasn't long before she called Biniam and the other hostages again, but John and the traffickers prohibited them from speaking to her like they used to.
Meron挂断了电话。但她忍不住。没过多久她又给Biniam和其他人质打了电话，但John和人贩子禁止他们像过去那样和她谈话。
Whenever I called, they would tell them to call me names. They would force them to call me names. And at the beginning, I was really hurt. They were saying the same thing-- don't call us here, you whore. We don't want you. You're just making money out of us.
每当我打电话时，他们就会告诉他们辱骂我。他们会强迫他们叫我那些难听的名字。起初，我真的很受伤。他们说的都是同一件事——别往这儿打，你这个妓女。我们不需要你。你只是在利用我们赚钱。
Eventually, Biniam, Semhar, and the rest of the group stopped talking to Meron completely.
最终，Biniam、Semhar和小组其余的人完全停止了与Meron的谈话。
It's been more than two years since that happened. Meron kept talking to other hostages on the phone, dozens of them. And without ever meaning to, she became one of the people Eritrean hostages and their families turned to for help. In those years, she's learned about the different traffickers and the different tricks they use, which traffickers can be relied on to let people go once they've paid, and which ones can't. One former hostage described Meron's phone calls this way-- she said when she talked to her family from the torture camp, all they would do is panic and freak out. Meron, on the other hand, was mostly calm and comforting. She'd give you clear updates and tell you what was being done to help. It was a relief.
距离那件事已经过去两年多了。Meron一直在电话里与其他人质谈话，有几十个。而且在不知不觉中，她成了厄立特里亚人质及其家属求助的对象之一。这些年来，她了解了不同的人贩子和他们使用的不同花招，哪些人贩子在收到钱后可以指望放人，哪些不可以。一位前人质这样描述Meron的电话——她说当她从酷刑营给家人打电话时，他们只会惊慌失措。而Meron则大多冷静而安慰。她会给你明确的更新，并告诉你正在做什么来提供帮助。这是一种解脱。
Meron isn't sure how many hostages she's helped get free over the years, but one of them is Biniam.
Meron不确定这些年来她帮助多少人质获得了自由，但其中之一就是Biniam。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Tomorrow, the 18th of July, it's going to be exactly two years.
明天，7月18日，正好是两年。
Biniam got out of Sinai in 2011. He's showing one of This American Life's producers around his small apartment in Israel, where he lives now.
Biniam于2011年逃离了西奈半岛。他正带着《This American Life》的一位制片人参观他在以色列的小公寓，他现在住在那儿。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Here, this is our bedroom. This is the bathroom. And this is our kitchen.
这儿，这是我们的卧室。这是浴室。这是我们的厨房。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
In all these apartments, we live, like, four people. And we three, we've been together in Sinai.
在所有这些公寓里，我们住了，像，四个人。我们三个，我们在西奈半岛时在一起。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
This is how my apartment looks like.
我的公寓就是这样。
My producer Brian Reed and I interviewed Biniam. He sat on his twin bed, next to an interpreter, and described what he remembered from the months he was talking to Meron. From the outside, the place they were held looked like the foundation of a house with a corrugated metal roof placed on top of it.
我的制片人Brian Reed和我采访了Biniam。他坐在双人床上，旁边有一个翻译，描述了他记得的谈话那几个月里Meron的情况。从外面看，他们被关的地方看起来像是一栋房子的地基，上面盖着瓦楞金属屋顶。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA]
[用提格雷语说话]
We don't see nothing. We are in the darkness. We are underground. Everything is dark. The only time we're going out, it's to use the bathroom, and only in the night time. And when we go out, you smell people smell, like dead body smell because everybody die, and they'd throw 'em out at this place just right outside.
我们什么也看不见。我们在黑暗中。我们在地下。一切都是黑的。我们唯一出去的时间是去上厕所，而且只有在晚上。当我们出去时，你闻到人们的气味，就像死人的气味，因为每个人都会死，他们会把他们扔在外面那个地方。
Who was holding you? What did they look like, and how many of them were there?
谁在扣押你？他们长什么样，有多少人？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
There were eight guards on us.
有八个守卫看着我们。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
There are elder ones, between 40 and 50 or 40 and 55 years old, controlling the torture and everything. And those who are really guarding us are the youngest ones.
有年长的，年龄在40到50或40到55岁之间，控制着酷刑和一切。那些真正看守我们的是最年轻的人。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
They'd been in the age of 20 or something.
他们大概20岁左右。
What was the demeanor of the torturers like--
折磨者在对你们做这些事情时的态度是什么样的——
That's my producer, Brian.
那是我的制片人，Brian。
--when they're doing these things to you?
——当他们对你们做这些事时？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Yeah. They need to be stoned to come and torture you. You can see that they took drugs because their eyes changed. They've been so red, and they look so angry, their eyes. And they're acting like they are angry. But they're also playing around while they're beating you up. They're laughing.
是。他们得嗑药来折磨你。你可以看出他们嗑了药，因为他们的眼睛变了。它们变得非常红，看起来很愤怒，他们的眼睛。他们表现得好像很愤怒。但他们在殴打你时也在玩闹。他们在笑。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
They have to take drugs. They are not that tough.
他们必须嗑药。他们没那么强硬。
How often did you guys exaggerate or lie to Meron because you were being forced to?
你们这些人因为被强迫，在多大程度上夸大其词或对Meron撒谎？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Many times, so many times.
很多次，太多次了。
Biniam told us that John, the Eritrean who was working with the traffickers, was constantly standing over them on the calls, telling the hostages to make thing sound as horrible as possible, that the traffickers were going to kill them now, that they'd harvest their organs. The hostages came to understand these were bluffs. And when Biniam told Meron that Semhar and the four other hostages had been freed, in fact, they were sitting right there in the room.
Biniam告诉我们，与人贩子合作的厄立特里亚人John经常站在他们通话的旁边，告诉人质把事情描述得尽可能糟糕，人贩子现在要杀了他们，他们要摘取他们的器官。人质们开始明白这些是虚张声势。当Biniam告诉Meron Semhar和其他四名人质已经获释时，事实上，他们就坐在那个房间里。
But Biniam and another hostage from this group that we spoke to said the torture they described on the phone to Meron was all real. It would have been hard to exaggerate, Biniam said, because it was so awful. He and the other hostage both remember at least four people who died while in captivity.
但Biniam和我们谈过的这组中的另一个人质说，他们在电话里向Meron描述的折磨都是真实的。Biniam说很难夸大，因为它太可怕了。他和另一个人质都记得在关押期间至少有四个人死亡。
How does the phone work, exactly? Do you guys have a lot of access to it? Or is it totally under the control of the guards and the traffickers?
电话到底是怎么运作的？你们真的有很大机会使用它吗？还是完全由守卫和人贩子控制？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
We can't touch the phone. There is this [TIGRINYA]. This is the translator. His name is John. He will put the phone on our ears while we're speaking.
我们不能碰电话。有这个[提格雷语]。这是翻译。他的名字叫John。当我们说话时，他会把电话放在我们耳朵上。
So wait. You never were-- we've listened to a lot of recordings of you talking to Meron. Through all of those, you were never actually holding the phone yourself?
等等。你们从来没有——我们听了很多你和Meron谈话的录音。在所有那些通话中，你实际上从来没有自己拿着电话？
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Yeah, we're not touching the phone. We're not touching the phone at all 'cause they're afraid we send messages.
是的，我们没碰电话。我们根本没碰过电话，因为他们害怕我们发送信息。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
So picture Meron's first phone call from Biniam's perspective. He's lying on the ground, shackled, blindfolded, almost completely in darkness. All of a sudden, John comes up to him and holds a cell phone to his ear. There's a woman's voice on the line saying, hello? She's from Sweden, and she's on the case, telling him to stay strong and not to worry.
所以从Biniam的角度想象Meron的第一个电话。他躺在地上，戴着手铐，蒙着眼睛，几乎完全在黑暗中。突然，John走过来，把手机放在他的耳边。电话那头有个女人的声音说，喂？她来自瑞典，她正在处理这件事，告诉他要保持坚强，不要担心。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I thought it's a dream, the first call I had with her. And the other way, I was suspicious because I thought, is it maybe a girl from another room being tortured like us, trying to convince us to talk to our family to get the money?
我以为那是梦，我跟她打的第一个电话。另一方面，我感到怀疑，因为我想，她也许是另一个房间里像我们一样被折磨的女孩，试图说服我们跟家人谈话以拿到钱？
So when Biniam first spoke to Meron, he felt the same way about her that she felt about him. He didn't know if she was trustworthy. But as Meron called more and more, he noticed that it put the traffickers in a better mood. They became encouraged that money was on the way. It seemed genuine. Sometimes they took his blindfold off to let him speak to her. And sometimes, amazingly, after a call from Meron, the traffickers wouldn't torture the hostages.
所以当Biniam第一次和Meron谈话时，他感受到的她和她感受到的他是一样的。他不知道她是否值得信任。但随着Meron打来的电话越来越多，他注意到这让人贩子的心情变好了。他们受到鼓舞，认为钱已经在路上了。这看起来是真的。有时他们摘下他的眼罩让他跟她说话。有时，令人惊奇的是，在Meron打来电话后，人贩子不会折磨人质。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
We'd been tortured every night. But there were nights when she calls, we'd not been tortured. We'd be sleeping without being tortured because of her call.
我们每晚都被折磨。但有些晚上她打电话时，我们没有被折磨。我们睡得没有被折磨，因为她的电话。
And Meron did something else for Biniam.
Meron还为Biniam做了另一件事。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Before Meron called, I was not calling my family. I'm coming from a very poor family. $20,000, I have never seen that before. So I never thought about asking my family. That's like giving them pain. Asking for $20,000, it means, like, torturing them. The best thing to do was let them think that I'm already dead.
在Meron打电话之前，我没有给家人打电话。我来自一个非常贫穷的家庭。2万美元，我以前从没见过那么多。所以我从未想过要问我的家人。那就像给他们痛苦。索要2万美元，这就像折磨他们。最好的办法就是让他们认为我已经死了。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
But then Meron called. She pushed me to call my family. She pushed me. She told me, tell them. Maybe they can do something. She gave me the idea. I would never do that. She gave me hope.
但后来Meron打电话来了。她推我给家人打电话。她推我。她告诉我，告诉他们。也许他们能做点什么。她给了我这个想法。我永远不会那样做。她给了我希望。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Biniam listened to Meron. He called his family and asked for the money. And to his utter surprise, they were able to scrounge together more than $10,000, getting money from relatives as far as Germany, Angola, and the United States. Biniam says they sent the money to John, but John told Biniam he never got it.
Biniam听了Meron的话。他给家人打电话要了钱。令他吃惊的是，他们竟然设法筹集了超过1万美元，从远在德国、安哥拉和美国的亲戚那里凑齐了钱。Biniam说他们把钱寄给了John，但John告诉Biniam他从来没收到。
Biniam was sold to another group of traffickers with Semhar. This was a group that was worse than the first. They raped Semhar in front of him. Other awful things happened until finally, one day, a guard came up to Biniam and took his chains off. He was so weak he could barely walk. So he rested at the camp for five days before the traffickers drove him and some other hostages to an area near the Israeli border. They crawled through a hole in what Biniam hoped was the border fence.
Biniam和Semhar被卖给了另一群人贩子。这群人比第一群更糟糕。他们当着他的面强奸了Semhar。其他可怕的事情发生了，直到有一天，一名守卫走过来解开了Biniam的锁链。他虚弱得几乎无法行走。所以他在营地里休息了五天，然后人贩子开车把他和其他一些人质带到了以色列边境附近的一个地方。他们爬过了一个Biniam希望是边境围栏的洞。
Eventually, some soldiers came up to him and told him he was in Israel. When he got access to a phone, he called Meron.
最终，一些士兵走过来告诉他他在以色列。当他能接触到电话时，他给Meron打了电话。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
She didn't even believe that I'm calling her from Israel. She were like-- we didn't talk. We were crying, both of us.
她甚至不相信我是从以色列打给她。她就像——我们没谈。我们哭了，我们两个。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Meron is actually everything for me.
Meron对我来说实际上就是一切。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
With the voice I hear from her, I feel more than I feel for my mother's voice.
听到她的声音，我感觉比我听到母亲的声音更有感觉。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
I owe her my life.
我的命是她救的。
Biniam's name's doing pretty well, considering. He has a job as a housekeeper at a hotel. He's slowly trying to pay his family back the thousands they raised for his ransom. To unwind, he writes poetry and songs, though he hasn't written about Sinai yet.
考虑到这些，Biniam的名字做得相当不错。他有一份在酒店做管家的工作。他正在慢慢尝试偿还家人为他的赎金筹集的数千美元。为了放松，他写诗和歌，虽然他还没写关于西奈半岛的。
But life in Israel is hard. Biniam still has injuries. He limps. His eyesight is impaired. He has trouble using his hands because he was chained for so long, which means his job making hotel beds is difficult. He applied for asylum when he arrived in Israel, but he says the government hasn't given him an answer on that. That means he gets no assistance with medical care, no legal work permit.
但在以色列生活很艰难。Biniam仍然有伤。他跛行。他的视力受损。他因为长时间戴手铐而无法使用双手，这意味着他做酒店铺床的工作很困难。他到达以色列时申请了庇护，但他说是政府还没给他答复。这意味着他没有得到医疗保健援助，也没有合法的就业许可。
And he's not alone. This is, in practice, Israel's policy towards migrants. In the most recent figures available from the UN High Commissioner for Refugees, Israel granted refugee status to less than 1% of people who might qualify, the lowest rate of any developed country. A US State Department report declared in 2012 that the Israeli government doesn't even process asylum applications from Eritreans.
他并不孤单。实际上，这就是以色列对待移民的政策。根据联合国难民署提供的最新数据，以色列批准了不到1%可能符合条件的难民身份，这是所有发达国家中最低的比例。一份美国国务院的报告在2012年宣称，以色列政府甚至不处理来自厄立特里亚人的庇护申请。
As best as we can tell, of the 29 hostages Biniam was originally held with, at least four died. One disappeared. One went back to Eritrea. And the rest, over 20 of them, are now in Israel. They try to get together when they can. Biniam says most of them are doing OK.
据我们所知，在Biniam最初被扣押的29名人质中，至少有四人死亡。一人失踪。一人回到了厄立特里亚。其余的人，超过20人，现在都在以色列。他们尽量聚在一起。Biniam说他们中的大多数人还好。
But you don't go through an experience like this and just move on. One last warning-- this next quote gets graphic. Here's Biniam.
但你不会经历这样的经历然后就继续前行。最后一次警告——接下来这段引述涉及生动描写。这是Biniam。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
In my mind, I don't really get over it.
在我心里，我真的没法释怀。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
It's like every second, it's walking around with me. I'm living in it. I don't know.
就像每一秒，它都在陪着我。我生活在其中。我不知道。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
What comes up always in my mind is about Semhar. I just open my eyes, and I see her, raping her. And I was praying for her to die.
我脑子里总是想到Semhar。我睁开眼睛，看到她，强奸她。我祈祷她死掉。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
That's the time she was drived crazy, where she get lost, mental lost.
那是她被逼疯的时候，她的精神丢失了。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
And I really see that all the time, again and again.
我真的总是看到这一切，一遍又一遍。
Biniam says Semhar's the person from his group who is doing the worst. She eventually made it to Israel, but only after an epic ordeal that went on long after Meron paid the $5,000 for her. She told Meron the whole story in an interview afterwards. Once the trafficker cut off Semhar from Meron and demanded $15,000 more, Semhar's mother in Eritrea, who is very poor, scraped together the money by begging people and taking loans. She sent it to the trafficker. Here's Meron.
Biniam说Semhar是他这组里情况最糟的人。她最终到了以色列，但那是在Meron为她支付了5000美元后又经历了一场史诗般的磨难。事后她在采访中告诉Meron整个故事。一旦人贩子把Semhar和Meron切断联系并要求再多要15000美元，Semhar在厄立特里亚、非常贫穷的母亲通过乞讨和借钱凑齐了这笔钱。她把钱寄给了人贩子。这是Meron。
And then he tried to sell her to another house. And when he took her to another house, they said, call your mom. She said, no. Over my dead body. You can kill me, but she refused to call to her mother. They kept torturing her, torturing her, and she refused. She said, just kill me. I'm not calling anyone begging for more money.
然后他试图把她卖到另一个房子。当他把她带到另一个房子时，他们说，给你的妈妈打电话。她说，不。我死也不会。无论你杀了我，但她拒绝给母亲打电话。他们不断折磨她，折磨她，而她拒绝了。她说，杀了我就行。我不向任何人乞求更多的钱。
Finally, these new traffickers cut their losses and dropped Semhar near the Israeli border. They told her to climb the fence to get into Israel. Semhar was weak from months at the torture camp, and before she could get across the fence, Egyptian guards spotted her and shot her in the leg.
最终，这些人贩子止损并将Semhar丢弃在以色列边境附近。他们告诉她爬过围栏进入以色列。Semhar因在酷刑营度过的数月而虚弱，在翻过围栏之前，埃及士兵发现了她并射中了她的腿。
They took Semhar to a hospital in Egypt, where she got treatment. Eventually, Semhar told her story to a nurse, who felt sorry for her. The nurse brought Semhar home for a while and later paid a smuggler to take her to Israel, where she lives today.
他们把Semhar带到了埃及的一家医院，在那里她得到了治疗。最终，Semhar把她的故事告诉了一位觉得她很可怜的护士。护士把Semhar带回家住了一段时间，后来付钱给一个走私者把她带到以色列，她今天住在那儿。
Meron eventually went to visit her. Semhar still has injuries and pain, which make it hard for her to work. Plus, Meron says--
Meron最终去拜访了她。Semhar仍有伤痛，使她很难工作。另外，Meron说——
She's now in a very bad situation where it's really hard to communicate. Mentally, she's not well. When we met, we hugged and we started crying, both of us. But suddenly, she just fainted as I was hugging her. And she fainted. And then subconsciously, she would get up and start screaming, you whore! Don't touch me. And she would hit anyone that's near her.
她现在处境非常糟糕，很难沟通。精神上，她不好。当我们见面时，我们拥抱并开始哭泣，我们两个。但突然，她在我拥抱她时就晕倒了。她晕倒了。然后潜意识里，她会起来开始尖叫，你这个妓女！别碰我。她会打任何靠近她的人。
So it took about five, 10 minutes, and then after that, she woke up. And she was like, hi, Meron. How are you? I'm so happy to see you. And so she's talking like a normal thing, like nothing has happened. And she doesn't remember what she just had done.
所以花了大约五、十分钟，然后之后，她醒了。她就像，嗨，Meron。你好吗？很高兴见到你。所以她说话很正常，好像什么都没发生。而且她不记得她刚才做了什么。
Meron tried to get Semhar to start seeing a doctor to help her deal with the trauma, but Semhar refused. She was living with a man in Tel Aviv who claimed to be a healer who could help exorcise her demons, and he wouldn't let her seek standard medical help. After Meron's trip to Israel, she pretty much lost touch with Semhar.
Meron试图让Semhar去看医生以帮助她处理创伤，但Semhar拒绝了。她和一个住在特拉维夫、声称自己是能帮助驱逐魔鬼的治疗师住在一起，他不让她寻求标准的医疗帮助。Meron去以色列之行后，她几乎和Semhar失去了联系。
In July 2012, on a trip to Israel, Meron did something she'd been waiting to do since she first started talking to the hostages-- meet some of them face-to-face. She sent word to former hostages that anyone who wanted to meet her should come to Levinsky Park, a place in Tel Aviv where a lot of Eritreans go.
2012年7月，在去以色列的旅途中，Meron做了她自第一次与人质谈话以来就一直想做的事情——与他们面对面交流。她传话给前人质，任何想见她的人都应该到莱文斯基公园来，那是特拉维夫一个很多厄立特里亚人会去的地方。
Meron got there in the early evening. A filmmaker was with her shooting video. She was excited, anxious.
Meron傍晚时分到达那里。一位电影制片人跟着她拍摄视频。她很兴奋，很焦虑。
So we're going to meet them. Yeah.
所以我们要去见他们了。对。
And far away, I could see a lot of people sitting on the grass. I was expecting about five or six would come to see me. But there were so many of them.
在远处，我可以看到很多人坐在草地上。我以为会有五六个人来看我。但他们有那么多人。
They are here.
他们在这儿。
What?
什么？
These are the people. Hi. Hi.
这些人就是。嗨。嗨。
Everybody stood up. I remember one of them came first and hugged me. And I just start crying.
每个人都站了起来。我记得其中一个先过来拥抱了我。然后我就开始哭。
Oh.
哦。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
Asking who are you, and he was saying, this person. And then the next person, the next person.
问你是谁，而他在说，这个人。然后是下一个人，下一个人。
[SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
[用提格雷语说话]。
About 20 people stood in a circle around Meron. She went up to each of them, one by one, and hugged them. There was a man whose cousin Meron had convinced to pay his ransom. I'm so happy you guys made it out safely, Meron said to him as they hugged. I'm so happy that I've seen you alive.
大约20个人站在Meron周围围成一个圈。她一个接一个地走向他们，拥抱了他们。有一个男人，Meron曾劝说他的表亲支付了他的赎金。我很高兴你们能安全出来，Meron在他们拥抱时对他说。我很高兴看到你们活着。
Another was a 14-year-old girl whose ransom Meron had paid with money she raised herself. The girl broke down in tears as soon as Meron got close to her.
另一个是一个14岁的女孩，Meron用她自己筹集的钱支付了赎金。当Meron靠近她时，女孩泪流满面。
Oh, my God. Oh. [SPEAKING TIGRINYA].
噢，天哪。噢。[用提格雷语说话]。
The group headed to a restaurant. Meron bought a round of beers. She seemed giddy. She was talking a lot, way more than the hostages, telling stories about this phone call or that phone call, about the time people thought the hostages were lying and making up a radio drama, or about the time she told John the translator off.
一行人前往一家餐馆。Meron买了一轮啤酒。她看起来头晕目眩。她说了很多，比人质多得多，讲述着这个电话或那个电话的故事，关于人们认为人质在撒谎并编造广播剧的时候，或者关于她告诉翻译John走开的时候。
This is Meron's life now. She still covers the torture camps on the radio. She helps other reporters do stories, too, speaks about Sinai at conferences. And she used her recordings to co-author a lengthy report that was submitted to the European Union Parliament. A few months ago, she even went to Sinai for the first time to try and get local sheikhs to address the hostage problem.
这就是Meron现在的生活。她仍然在广播中报道酷刑营。她帮助其他记者做故事，在会议上谈论西奈半岛。她用她的录音共同撰写了一份提交给欧洲议会的详尽报告。几个月前，她甚至第一次去了西奈半岛，试图让当地的酋长处理人质问题。
And then, of course, she still gets phone calls from hostages and their families all the time.
当然，她仍然随时接到人质及其家人的电话。
My life has changed totally. I don't know how to lead a normal life right now because I feel bad if I'm laughing. I feel bad if I'm going out. Sometimes, they would make a missed call while I'm eating my dinner. I tried to talk to them while I'm eating. But I try to chew like as slow as I can so that they don't notice that I'm eating because I would feel bad that I'm eating and they don't have anything to eat.
我的生活完全改变了。我现在不知道该怎么过正常生活，因为如果我在笑，我会感觉不好。如果我出去，我会感觉不好。有时，当我在吃晚饭时他们会打来一个未接来电。我试着在吃饭时和他们说话。但我尽量嚼得尽可能慢，这样他们就不会注意到我在吃东西，因为我会因为我在吃东西而他们却没有任何东西吃而感觉不好。
I mean, that has become my life. This has become my call for life, actually. I just feel that this was meant for me, and this is my call. I see it as part of my life, stopping this. I see them as my family.
我是说，那已经成了我的生活。这实际上成了我的一生使命。我只是觉得这是命中注定给我的，这是我的召唤。我把它看作是我生活的一部分，阻止这一切。我把他们看作我的家人。
When was the last time you talked to a hostage?
你上次和人质谈话是什么时候？
Yeah, last night, around midnight.
是，昨晚，大约午夜。
Yowei Shaw. Brian Reed produced her story. As I mentioned earlier, since we first reported this story in 2013, the Egyptian military increased its presence in the Sinai, putting a stop to the Bedouin torture camps there. But people are still fleeing Eritrea in large numbers. They're paying smugglers to take them to the Mediterranean for a shot at getting on a boat to Europe.
Yowei Shaw。Brian Reed制作了她的故事。正如我之前提到的，自我们2013年首次报道这个故事以来，埃及军方加强了在西奈半岛的存在，制止了那里的贝都因酷刑营。但人们仍在大量逃离厄立特里亚。他们付钱给走私者带他们去地中海，希望能上船去欧洲。
And just like in the Sinai, these smugglers often take Eritreans hostage and torture them, trying to extort money from their families. Meron says she gets more calls from hostages now than she ever has.
正如在西奈半岛一样，这些走私者经常扣押厄立特里亚人作为人质并折磨他们，试图从他们的家属那里勒索钱财。Meron说她现在接到的电话比以往任何时候都多。
And a new danger has emerged in the last few years. Even if you manage to avoid a bad smuggler, there's a chance that you could get caught by ISIS on your way to Europe. And unlike the smugglers or the Bedouins in Sinai, they're not interested in money. They try to get the hostages to join ISIS. And if they refuse, they kill them.
过去几年里出现了新的危险。即使你设法避开了坏走私者，你也有可能在去欧洲的路上被ISIS抓住。而且不像西奈半岛的走私者或贝都因人，他们对钱不感兴趣。他们试图让人质加入ISIS。如果他们拒绝，他们就会杀死他们。
As for the situation in Israel, according to the Hebrew Immigrant Aid Society, which works with migrants there, there are roughly 30,000 Eritrean migrants living in Israel who made it through the Sinai. But as of last year, the state has still only recognized fewer than 1% of Eritrean asylum applicants, according to the UN, leaving thousands of Eritreans in a holding pattern, including Biniam, who's still in Israel. Meron tells us he's now married.
至于以色列的情况，根据与移民合作的希伯来移民援助协会，大约有30000名厄立特里亚移民生活在以色列，他们成功穿过了西奈半岛。但截至去年，根据联合国的数据，该国仍然只承认了不到1%的厄立特里亚庇护申请者，这让数千名厄立特里亚人处于停滞状态，包括仍留在以色列的Biniam。Meron告诉我们他现在结婚了。
Semhar eventually got out of Israel. She's now living in Sweden, not far from Meron, actually. Meron says she's taking classes. She's doing better mentally. She recently got married. Semhar invited Meron to the wedding. Meron says it was the best day she's had since the calls began.
Semhar最终离开了以色列。她现在住在瑞典，实际上离Meron不远。Meron说她正在上课。她的精神状况正在好转。她最近结婚了。Semhar邀请Meron去参加婚礼。Meron说那是电话开始以来她度过的最好的一天。
[MUSIC - "IF YOU CALL" BY SHARON JONES AND THE DAP KINGS]
[音乐 - "IF YOU CALL" BY SHARON JONES AND THE DAP KINGS]
Well, our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak. Other staff for today's show-- Phia Bennin, Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today show is Julie Snyder. Production help from Emmanuel Dzotsi. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Other staff-- Elise Bergerson, Emily Condon, Kimberly Henderson, and Seth Lind. Music help from Damian Graef, from Rob Geddis. Research help from Michelle Harris.
今天我们的节目由Lisa Pollak制作。今天节目的其他工作人员——Phia Bennin、Alex Blumberg、Ben Calhoun、Sarah Koenig、Miki Meek、Jonathan Menjivar、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike。我们今天节目的高级制作人是Julie Snyder。Emmanuel Dzotsi提供了制作帮助。我们的技术总监是Matt Tierney。其他人员——Elise Bergerson、Emily Condon、Kimberly Henderson和Seth Lind。Damian Graef和Rob Geddis提供了音乐帮助。Michelle Harris提供了研究帮助。
Research and Tigrinya translations by Hanna Haile. Tigrinya interpreters who you heard during this hour-- Bealfan Haile, Helen Ghebreselassie, Ayda Equbay, Gideon Gebreyesus, and Phillipos Tesfai. Thanks also today to Lina Attalah, Jerry Simpson, Shahar Shoham, Claire Beston, Sigal Rozen, John Stauffer, Maya Paley, and Isayas Sium.
研究和提格雷语翻译由Hanna Haile完成。你们在这一个小时里听到的提格雷语口译员——Bealfan Haile、Helen Ghebreselassie、Ayda Equbay、Gideon Gebreyesus和Phillipos Tesfai。还要感谢Lina Attalah、Jerry Simpson、Shahar Shoham、Claire Beston、Sigal Rozen、John Stauffer、Maya Paley和Isayas Sium。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia, who's been getting into-- and, OK, I know how this sounds-- Eritrean stand-up. Seriously, he's been doing comedy bits for me all week around the office. I tell him, Torey, they're not that funny. He says--
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《This American Life》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生，他一直沉迷于——而且，我知道这听起来怎么样——厄立特里亚脱口秀。真的，他整个星期都在办公室给我讲笑话段子。我告诉他，Torey，它们没那么好笑。他说——
I don't know. Like, it's hard. You have to understand Tigrinya to get it.
我不知道。就像，这很难。你得懂提格雷语才能理解。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《This American Life》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "IF YOU CALL" BY SHARON JONES AND THE DAP KINGS]
[音乐 - "IF YOU CALL" BY SHARON JONES AND THE DAP KINGS]